avec un petit jeu d'accord devenir
acrobates ou magiciens le temps d'une
journée
c'est le pari du cirque paradiso qui
propose des ateliers interactifs aux
visiteurs merci des cartes ou et piocher
car j'ai montré et d'après jérid en a un
paquet et et après on au noir il a
trouvé la tarte
cette journée dans les coulisses du
cirque connaît des adeptes chez des
petits comme chez les plus grands c'est
très bien déjà pour sa porte au niveau
des enfants surtout de la connaissance
au niveau des animaux au niveau de ce
que c'est qu'un cirque en même temps ben
voilà ils partent à la découverte un peu
de tout ça c'est sympa c'est ce
convivial c'est que ils sont
accueillants vraiment tout se passe bien
c'est on me ravit après neuf ans de
tournée dans tout l'hexagone
le cirque paradiso à poser
définitivement ses valises sur ce
terrain dans le cher et veut faire
découvrir l'envers du décor c'est
vraiment une envie qu'on avait de faire
découvrir vraiment le milieu du circle
qui est pas toujours connus qui des fois
un peu décrédibilisé et comme ça c'était
une manière aussi de montrer plein de
choses notamment avec les animaux
comment on vivait avec eux comme on
était même sur les répétitions du
spectacle comme on monte un spectacle et
tout ça oui c'était important ça il est
possible de venir admirer pin-up la
mascotte du cirque du mercredi au
dimanche jusqu'au 29 août prochain